hey there my name is Alex this
fundamentally is a video about
data more specifically it's a video
about data scraping and the sorts of
feedback loops that can occur sometimes
when using scraped data over long
periods of
time it's also a video about magic the
Gathering although hopefully I've made
it somewhat accessible to people who
haven't made the terrible mistake of
playing this
game magic The Gather ing was released
in 1993 and followed the template of a
lot of card games there was an opponent
to defeat and defeating them requires
some little dudes that do things as well
as other types of
cards it's a game whose play formats are
mostly designed for two players which
always brings up the natural question of
well what do my other one to four
friends do just stand there looking sad
on this flooded
strand I certainly remember being 12 and
sitting on the floor with with five
other kids playing a game that gets
abandoned after 90 minutes but that's
not
ideal enter Elder Dragon Highlander
known more commonly now simply as EDH or
Commander EDH is a format with four
players where each person picks one of
their little guys to be a commander that
they can play multiple times at
escalating cost with origins in Alaska
in the late
1990s the format gradually gained
population ity over time with Wizards of
the Coast finally printing a set
specifically for the format in
2011 this set was more of a toolbox than
anything else the pre-built decks were
technically playable but not very good
containing a mish mash of themes and
random unrelated cards they were
seemingly intended to be hammered out
with other cards into a more functional
deck this is probably a good thing as it
gave newer players a gentle push toward
building their own
deck building a deck is one of the most
fundamental processes in any collectible
card game but people don't often think
about the intricacies of how decks
actually get
built it usually starts with formulating
basic ideas and a bunch of
rumaging whoa plumon spontaneous flight
that's a Wombo
Combo by rumaging I hear me looking
through cards this can be looking
through physical cards in a collection
or looking through card galleries or
even performing searches with websites
like
gatherer with these various methods of
rumaging you're going to be asking
questions like is this card good does it
fit into my
deck how many cards of this type should
I be
running how will this card work against
the people I'm likely to play
against does this do this card fit the
aesthetic of my deck where all the
facial expressions in the art are
funny yes yes it
does different players will be asking
different questions but every player
uses some criteria or
other another major piece of deck
building is looking at other people's
decks either physically or through
websites where people post their
decks this could be the last step in
deck building to find cards you might
have missed the first step where you're
trying to get a bit of inspiration or
somewhere in the middle where you're
trying to hammer out the structure of
the
deck now this is all well and good but
let's try out a little thought
experiment and say that we're trying to
use the power of technology to simplify
deck
building a lot of the rumaging either
digital or physical is hard to directly
replace but the act of looking at other
people's decks theoretically could
be looking at individual decks is
relatively slow since each individual
deck has the biases of its deck builder
meaning that unless you really trust the
deck builder it's a good idea to look at
multiple different
decks what if we could look at all
similar decks at the same time seeing
cards based on how often other people
choose to run them this is where EDH
wreck comes in for the commander
format in theory a website that
Aggregates deck lists is going to allow
sorting through a ton of potential card
choices very
efficiently we aren't trusting the card
analysis of just a single person but
rather the analysis of the collective
thereby reducing the risk of bias now
something to watch out for would be if
these decks are influenced by each other
which could compound Bad Card Decisions
by
people this effect will probably always
exist to some extent since people look
at each other's deck s and generally
exist in the same
ecosystem but by default it likely isn't
going to be pronounced enough to
undermine the idea behind an aggregating
website the fact that people aren't
perfect analysts of cards and sometimes
trust other people's imperfect analyses
isn't a particularly devastating
critique rather it's more along the
lines of saying that we live in a
society everything I just said applies
to EDH Rec as it existed at its launch
in
2015 as a website EDH scrapes deck lists
from websites such as archade and MTG
goldfish where players post their deck
lists to receive
feedback these deck lists are then
organized by Commander as well as by
other categories like price and sub
themes and then within each tab cards
are displayed by the frequency with
which they appear in
decks if I'm trying to build an arcades
the strategist deck I don't don't have
to scroll down far to find overgrown
battlements a card that is found in 95%
of the arcad Decks that EDH has
scraped nice that seems good I should
put that in my
deck ah Shield wall Sentinel that goes
in
too wow I've got all these great cards
from my Defender deck and I didn't need
to put in very much effort to find them
time to log in my favorite website and
post this deck so I can send it to all
my friends
it's at this point that EDH Rec goes wow
a new deck was posted time to add this
useful data to my arcad the strategist
page so that other players can benefit
from this original card
analysis you might be able to see the
problem here in this case instead of
getting data from independently
operating deck builders EDH Rec is
receiving a regurgitation of its own
aggregated data plus maybe a bit of the
deck Builder's discretion on which
specific cards to
add a little bit of this type of deck
doesn't really change EDH Rex
methodology but since all posted decks
are treated equally and decks made
heavily using Eda Tre are much quicker
and easier to build than decks built
from the ground up the proportion of
decks built mainly with EDH wreck
naturally balloons over
time as this proportion increases we get
two compounding
effects for one cards that didn't quite
make it into the EDH Rec list SS or
which are lower on the page get
artificially tanked
further this in turn makes the EDH Rec
card suggestions artificially sluggish
to changes in how decks are played and
which decks are played since for every
time a player thoughtfully puts a less
played card in their deck there's
another player building a deck straight
off the EDH Rec page that doesn't
include that card because they weren't
presented with
it secondly the card's already high up
in the EDH Rec recommendations are
bolstered regardless of how useful they
actually
are the cards at the very top are
generally good but there are a lot of
cards that get played in 10 to 50% of
decks that are
peculiar when I think of the archetypal
overplayed card in the format it's one
that is questionable on its own but is
good in a game where the decks Commander
sticks on the battlefield Untouched by
other players at the table
you could also call this a win more card
a card that's bad when a player is
behind or when a game is tight but
strong when a player is already
ahead commanders are the flashiest and
most visible part of Commander decks so
even without something like EDH rack
players tend to overrate cards that are
better when the commander sticks to the
board EDH Rec compounds this as these
questionable Synergy cards are pushed
high up in the results and and tell
players that they're played in 40% of
decks thereby amplifying the deck
building mistakes of EDH
players as an example of this a friend
of mine was building a Volo guide to
monsters deck
recently let's call him
Bartholomew Bartholomew sent me the list
asking for suggestions and it had
several of these win more cards with the
two that caught my eye being Second
Harvest and junk
Winder these cards aren't bad
necessarily but he was building a deck
with a number of powerful format Staples
like ristic studies and consecrated
Sphinx and by comparison these win more
cards are really only good when Volo
sticks around for multiple turns in a
row and if you're that far ahead that
that's the case there are much stronger
things that you're probably able to
do I told bolamu that he should cut
these cards and S wondered to myself why
he DED them when I went to the EDH Rec
page for Volo out of curiosity a bit
later I got my answer the website is
here to quickly inform me that 48% of
volod deex run junk Winder and 47% run
Second Harvest proportions high enough
to make even an experienced player think
twice about calling them bad
cards this also speaks to a broader
issue with giving High powerered deck
building tools to inexperienced players
EDH rack can tell people what cards are
being played but it can't tell them why
or what they contribute towards a
well-rounded deck there are some pieces
of a deck that are clear as to why they
run I want to run axebane Guardian
because my commander Arc the strategist
encourages me to have lots of Defenders
and I run Slaughter the strong because
most of my creatures have zero
power however there are other cards that
aren't as obvious why run path the exile
or
negate they don't relate to my commander
in any direct way they just interact
with my
opponent a lot of players don't
understand why these cards are good and
I'd speculate that this results in these
players adding only a handful of these
cards and adding them out of a sense of
obligation rather than any Clear
Vision this results in a casual EDH
format where most of the decks are
stuffed with win more only good with the
commander cards with these cards taking
up space that could have been occupied
with cards that are better in the deck
but whose purpose is less immediately
obvious a general Trend I've noticed is
that most casual EDH decks don't run
nearly enough of two key things pressure
and
removal pressure essentially is just
things that make your opponent's life
tools go down usually creatures that can
attack
them if you know your opponent is
playing a deck stuffed with win more
cards
one that will do nothing and have no
defenses until later snowball's out of
control a natural response should be to
turn your creatures sideways and punish
that deck before they randomly pop
off removal is similar if you know your
opponent is running a deck loaded up
with cards that do nothing when their
Commander doesn't stick around then all
you have to do to keep that player in
check is make sure a doomblade gets
tossed at their Commander whenever it's
played and that's a small price to pay
to basically shut down a play
so what does it mean that people don't
run enough pressure and
removal it means that the sorts of decks
that are stuffed with win more cards go
unpunished and large sections of the
Casual Commander format become akin to
multiplayer solitare with each player
racing toward their own win plan and
just praying that they can outrun their
opponent I don't love this fact and this
is where some people might say but Alex
EDH is a fun casual format play with
your
friends this is true and honestly if
doing wacky hijinks with your commander
and playing against other people doing
the same is something you enjoy I'm not
here to tell you you're doing anything
wrong I'm also not telling you you're
doing anything wrong if you use EDH Rec
to help you build your decks I use it
pretty regularly when building Commander
decks typically in the later stages of
decks where I'm looking for cards I
might have missed in my earlier
stages it's a good res source as long as
you treat the cards that it shows you
with the same criticality as cards you
find anywhere else and also recognize
that there are cards it's not showing
you if there's any message I want people
to take away from all this it's just
that edre isn't a magical
website it's a website with all the
advantages and all the flaws of anything
in our Modern Age that exists through
the wonders of sifting through data
slurry and that fact should form the way
we use it